Welcome back.
We will now do a momentum
problem in two dimensions.
So let's see what
we have here.
So we have this ball A and we
could maybe even think of it
as maybe what's going on on the
surface of a pool table.
We have ball A and it's moving
with its 10 kilograms. So
these numbers are the
mass of the balls.
This is a 10 kilogram ball and
it's moving to the right at 3
meters per second.
And then it hits this ball, B,
which is a 5 kilogram ball.
And then we know that ball A,
ball A kind of ricochets off
of ball B and gets set onto
this new trajectory.
Now, instead of going due right,
it's going at a 30
degree angle to, I guess we
could say, horizontal.
It's going in a 30 degree angle
at 2 meters per second.
And the question is, what is
the velocity of ball B?
So velocity is both magnitude
and direction.
So we need to figure
out essentially,
what is ball B doing?
Ball B is going to be going--
We can just think about it.
If you ever played pool, we
could guess that ball B is
going to go roughly
in that direction.
But we need to figure out
exactly what the angle is and
exactly what its velocity is.
So let's do this problem.
So at first you're saying, oh,
Sal, this looks confusing.
You know, I know momentum
should be
conserved and all that.
But now we have these vectors
and there's two dimensions and
how do I do that?
And the key here is that there's
just really one more
step when you're working on it
in two dimensions or really
three dimensions or an
arbitrary number of
dimensions.
When we did one dimension, you
made sure that momentum was
conserved in that
one dimension.
So when you do two dimensions,
what you do is you figure out
the initial momentum in each
of the dimensions.
So you break it up into the
x and y components.
And then you say the final
momentum of both objects are
going to equal the initial x
momentum and are going to
equal the initial y momentum.
So let's figure out the
initial x momentum.
So P for momentum.
Because the m is for mass.
So let's say the initial
momentum in the x direction--
And we don't have to write
initial or final because
really, the total momentum in
the x direction is always
going to be the same.
So let's say what the initial--
Actually, let me
write initial just so it hits
the point home that initial
and final don't change.
So the initial momentum
in the x direction.
So i for initial, x-- I should
do something better than keep
writing these subscripts
--is equal to what?
Well ball B has no
initial velocity,
so it has no momentum.
Ball A is 10 kilograms.
And what is its velocity
in the x direction?
Well all of its velocity
is in the x direction.
So it's 3.
I mean, this is only moving
in the x direction.
So the momentum in the x
direction is 30 kilogram
meters per second.
Mass times velocity, kilogram
And what's the initial momentum
in the y direction?
Well B isn't moving at
all, so it has no
momentum in any direction.
And A, all of A's movement
is in the x direction.
It's not moving at an angle
or up at all, so it has no
momentum in the y direction.
So we immediately know that
after the collision, the
combined momentum of both of
these balls in the x direction
has to be 30, and the combined
momentum of both of these
balls in the y direction
has to be 0.
So let's figure out what A's
momentum in the x and y
directions are.
So to figure out what A's
momentum is, we just have to
figure out what A's velocity in
the x and y directions are
and then multiply that
times the mass.
Because mass doesn't
have any direction.
So let's figure out the x and y
components of this velocity.
Let's do the x component
of the vector first.
So the x is just this vector.
Change colors to keep
things interesting.
The y is this vector.
That is the y component.
And so, what are those?
And this hopefully, is going to
be almost second nature to
you if you've been watching
all of the other videos on
Newton's laws.
This is just our trigonometry
and we can write out our
SOH-CAH-TOA again.
And I reassure you, this is
the hardest part of any of
these multi-dimensional trig
problems-- Multi-dimensional
physics problems, which really
are just trig problems.
So if we want to figure out
the x component, so the
velocity of A in the
x direction,
what is it equal to?
Well this is adjacent
to the angle.
We know the hypotenuse.
So we know VA sub x or the
velocity of A in the x
direction over the hypotenuse,
over 2 meters per second, is
equal to what?
Adjacent over hypotenuse.
Cosine.
Is equal to cosine
of 30 degrees.
Or the velocity of A in the x
direction is equal to 2 cosine
of 30 degrees.
What's cosine of 30 degrees?
It's square root of 3 over 2.
This is square root
of 3 over 2.
And square root of 3 over
2 times 2 is equal to
square root of 3.
So this is equal to the square
root of 3 meters per second.
And what is the velocity of
A in the y direction?
Well hopefully, this second
nature to you as well.
But since opposite over
hypotenuse is equal to the
sine of 30.
So VA in the y direction is
equal to 2 times the sine of
30 degrees.
The sine of 30 degrees is 1/2.
So this is 1/2.
1/2 times 2 is equal to
1 meter per second.
So after the collision,
A is moving at 1
meter per second up.
One meter per second in
the upwards direction.
And it's moving at square root
of 3 meters per second in the
rightwards direction.
So what is going to be A's
momentum in each of the
directions?
Well, we figured out its
velocity, so we just multiply
each of the velocities
times the mass.
So A has a mass of 10 kilograms.
And this is going
to be the final momentum.
Momentum of A in the x direction
is going to equal
square root of 3 times 10.
Square root of 3 is the
velocity, 10 is the mass.
So it's 10 square roots of 3
kilogram meters per second.
And the momentum of A in the y
direction is going to be-- and
since it's going up, we'll say
its positive --it's 1 meters
per second is the velocity
times the mass.
So 10 times 1 is 10 kilogram
meter per second.
So now let's figure out B.
Let's do the y direction first
because they add up to 0.
I'm going to switch colors.
We know that the momentum
of-- and this
is after the collision.
The momentum of A in the y
direction plus momentum of B
in the y direction have
to equal what?
What was the initial momentum
in the y direction?
Right, it was 0.
There was no movement in the
y direction initially.
We know the momentum of
A in the y direction.
It's 10.
10 kilogram meters per second
plus the momentum of B in the
y direction is equal to 0.
So solving for this, just
subtract 10 from both sides.
So the momentum of B in the
y direction is equal to 10
kilogram meters per second.
You know the units.
So if its momentum is 10 in the
y direction, what is its
velocity in the y direction?
Well, momentum is equal to
mass times velocity.
So we know that 5 times the
velocity in the y direction--
that's its mass --is
equal to 10.
10 is its momentum.
So the velocity of the y
direction of B must be 2
meters per second.
So there we go.
We figured out B's velocity.
And so let's say this is B's
velocity vector in the y
direction is-- And this is
a minus because this is
equal to minus 10.
So it's going down.
It was a velocity of positive
1 going up and then the
minuses carry through and this
is a velocity of minus 2
meters per second for B
in the y direction.
So now let's figure
out the velocity
of B in the x direction.
And I'm running out of space
and it's getting messy.
But we just have to remember
that the momentum of B in
the-- The momentum of A in the
x direction, which is 10
square root of 3, plus momentum
of B in the x
direction has to equal what?
It has to equal the initial
momentum in the x direction,
which is 30.
So to figure out the momentum
of B in the x direction, we
just subtract 10 square
root of 3 from 30.
And let's do that.
So let's figure out 3 square
root times 10 equals.
And then subtract
that from 30.
And we get let's
just say 12.7.
So we know that the momentum
of B in the x direction is
equal to 12.7, 12.7 kilogram
meters per second.
And we know the momentum, so we
just divide by the mass and
we get its velocity in
the x direction.
So 12.7 divided by 5.
So velocity of B in
the x direction is
12.7 divided by 5.
12.7 divided by 5 is equal to
2.54 meters per second.
So its velocity in the
x direction is
2.54 meters per second.
So it's going faster
in both directions.
I'm not going to figure out the
angle here because I've
actually run out of time.
But if you were to add these
two vectors, you'd get an
angle something like this.
And you could figure out the
angle by taking the arc tan.
Well, I won't go into the--
that's a complexity right now.
Actually, I'll do that in the
next video just so I won't
leave you hanging.
But we know what the x and y
components of B's velocity is.
See you in the next video.